[Musique]
doré sucre est une forme de tourbillon
qui embaume la maison à la cuisson c'est
la brioche à la cannelle les flèches
estermann termine son tout dernier test
de cuisson par essais et erreurs
elle cherche à développer la recette de
la brioche à la cannelle parfaite c'est
le goût d'une brioche de son enfance
mais moi j'adore les brioches et avec
enel et j'ai toujours été un peu triste
qu'au québec on trouve très peu parce
que dans mon enfance ma grand mère on
les faisait à manitoba
elle était de l'héritage ukrainienne et
polonaises et les ukrainiens les
polonais font beaucoup beaucoup de ses
jambes de pain brioché débarque à des
débrayages à kanel tuteur de choses
la recette aurait différentes origines
et viendrait surtout de l'europe du nord
la scandinavie l'amérique du nord et
l'allemagne ont souvent les mêmes
techniques et ingrédients de base
mon meilleur souvenir des bruches à
canal c'est que y avait une boulangerie
qui s'appelait le granby chg des
allemands qui avaient cette boulangerie
et il y avait des unités non plaques de
brioches à la cannelle et je cherche
toujours ce même goût tout le temps dans
les prêcheurs et cannelle et ce fut
tellement heureuse de voir que ses
revenus si tendance maintenant ces
brioches plusieurs boulangeries en
propose est l'une des versions les plus
connus est ancienne et suédoises
comment bien suédois une brioche en cela
on dit canet le bull pour cannes elle
exactement donc double ça me dirait un
prix un choix qui confie ses fans
cetto ne dit pas c'est ce que ça fait
partie de nos gâteries se doivent au lac
l'essonne est un chef suédois
il travaille à l'auberge saint-gabriel
mais aujourd'hui il nous reçoit chez lui
dans la cuisine de sa maison dans la
préparation des cannelle bulard des
brioches à la cannelle typiquement
suédoise ont dit brioche
mais la technique est tout de même un
peu différente de celle d'une brioche et
elle s'apparente davantage à un pain
fait à base de lait qu'est le prêche à
15 sud ouest c'est en brioche temps
qu'elle signait pas d'offre dont il est
patent de beurre donc une brioche
monstre avec des oeufs et du bugue en
ont rêvé dans la pâte au travail
longtemps cette sympathie aux bases du
lait et du beurre
donc je fais fort montbard et quand ces
fonds du jeu je veux mettre mon l'aide
il l'est il doit être la couverture de
corps 20 37 degrés celsius pour que la
levure s'active tous rapidement comme
tout brioche
il faut de la levure elle permettra à la
patte de faire une première levée et de
doublé en volume
ensemble les ingrédients apporteront une
texture aéré et moelleuse à la pâte et
l'autre secret de la brioche à la
cannelle suédoise et l'ajout de la
cardamome dans la pâte
le show si importante qu'elle la
cannelle goût très parfumé et très fun
note brioches à la cannelle ce mélange
de cannelle bury suc et tartiner sur la
pâte ensuite roulé façonné en rondelles
faut qu'il y ait une balance will de
beurre et de sucre mais il faut que le
balance
dans ce restaurant du vieux-montréal
matt confectionne des brioches au
chocolat et termine le glaçage du sticky
banc une des versions de la brioche à la
cannelle américaine est plus celui
quelque chose qu'on tourne aux états
unis surtout dans le sud
mais c'est avec vue de glaçage beaucoup
de plus en plus de cette version
classique américaine diana développer
des versions différentes de la brioche
avec chocolat banane parfois même bluets
pour nous on a fait une galerie comme un
peu plus heures que ces bruits secs si
vous voulez quand même en train entre h
c'est ça d'après cet ici avec de
chocolat depuis l'ouverture du
restaurant la brioche au chocolat banane
est au menu
dyan en a fait aussi un incontournable
dans son livre de recettes
on a ouvert des essais pour moi c'est
très nostalgique mais c'est comme ça
c'est quelque chose que j'ai acheté une
fois que j'ai ensuite il ya plusieurs
variations de tout ce qu'on fait avec
cette pâte
on m'a même journée qu'on appelle le
journée de vue relationnel ensuite les 4
octobre
c'est pas quelque chose beaucoup fait ça
ces leçons pour voir si les libéraux
sont très libres pour moi c'est très
important qu'il sait pas trop cuit donc
il faut quand même c'est une belle
coloration au tour mais il faut pas
qu'il soit sec et aussi évoqué le coeur
pour moi c'est le meilleur parti sans ce
qui est très très très moelleux très
tendre une brioche une boisson chaude
c'est le moment de faire comme les
suédois le fica s'est faite le matin ça
donne le le soir l'après midi ou au
travail et à 10 heures avec les amis
avec et avec la famille juste arrêter un
peu un peu de détente
c'est mon enfance en fait toute ma vie
d'errance et ma mère ont fait c'est tout
le temps et je mangeais quand j'étais
jeune donc c'est vraiment l'odeur de
l'enfance